in the aftermath of the Battle of
Winterfell beyond the thousands of men
left dead and injured allegiances have
shifted alliances have changed and of
course there's still another war to
fight Cersei is still waiting and her
army is ready to attack Daenerys John
and their allied forces with just a
handful of episodes remaining in the
final season there's plenty left to
accomplish between the quest for the
throne as well as another war so here's
everything you need to know about the
last of the starts the fourth episode of
the last season of Game of Thrones as
you might expect after the carnage of
the Battle of Winterfell the last of the
starts opens with a slow and emotional
funeral sequence characters like
Daenerys and Sansa are given the chance
to mourn loved ones including Jorah
Mormont and fian Greyjoy who gave their
lives during the battle after a moving
speech by John the entire crew retires
to the Great Hall of Winterfell to
celebrate their victory giving the
characters as well as the audience a
brief respite from the violence and
sadness during the celebration Daenerys
takes a moment to win some more brownie
points with the northerners by naming
ginjury Robert Baratheon's illegitimate
son and sole remaining heir as the Lord
of storms in encouraged by his new title
and still stuck on his one night with
Arya Gendry rushes off to propose to his
ladylove only to be gently yet firmly
rebuffed arya definitely isn't looking
to get wiped up anytime soon and being
the lady of a grand castle probably
isn't quite as appealing as stealing
faces and killing enemies so
unfortunately for ginjury he'll probably
have to find a different lady to help
run his castle at this point it's
looking like robert's dream of joining
the Baratheon and Stark houses may not
come true after all
ever since she travelled with the
Kingslayer several seasons ago and saw
his fall from celebrated night to
one-handed enemy of Queen Cersei Brienne
has clearly had feelings for Jaime and
it certainly seems as if he returned to
those feelings from the time he saved
her from a bear pit to the moment he
dubbed her the first female Knight of
the Seven Kingdoms
after Tyrion shrewdly reveals that
Brienne is a virgin during a drinking
game the formidable fighter is
uncharacteristically embarrassed but
once Jaime comes to comfort her she gets
over that embarrassment pretty quickly
Jaime however has to choose where his
allegiances lie despite his seemingly
close relationship with both Tyrion and
Brienne he ends up heading right back to
Cersei as he leaves in the middle of the
night Brienne rush
to bring him back to the northern side
but he insists he's really just as
hateful as a sister and leaves her
heartbroken a Lannister always pays his
debts but which scores will Jamie be
hoping to settle when he gets back to
King's Landing the news that Jon Snow
isn't Ned Stark's bastard at all but the
legitimate son of Prince Rhaegar
Targaryen and Ned's sister Liana has
been out in the open for viewers since
season seven
when bran and Sam discovered the truth
about his secret royal lineage as the
person with the strongest claim to the
Iron Throne Jon has unwittingly made
himself an enemy of just about everyone
on the show especially his new
girlfriend Daenerys who is also his aunt
in case all of this needed to get
weirder and worse even though Daenerys
begs Jon not to tell his sisters about
his real parentage John can't help
himself
swearing both Arya and Sansa to secrecy
as he spills the beans about his royal
blood despite her vow
Sansa quickly tells her former husband
Tyrion about who John really is and
naturally he immediately tells the
secret to Varys with information this
important it was always impossible that
characters wouldn't find out but this
turn of events is bad news for both John
and Daenerys who both stand to lose a
lot the minute the truth of his lineage
truly goes public despite the recent
victory against the army of the dead
Daenerys is more on edge than ever even
during the post battle celebration at
Winterfell where she finds herself
isolated from the crowd and left to
wander off alone seemingly angry at her
failure to make friends among the
northerners by the end of the episode
Daenerys has faced two massive losses
both pushing her to her absolute
breaking point not only does she lose
ships and cavalry during a surprise
attack on her fleet courtesy of euron
greyjoy
and Cersei Lannister ZAR me she loses
her Ragle
who becomes the first of her dragons to
be killed by humans with the aid of
massive ballistas known as scorpions in
the aftermath her best friend and
confidant miss on day ends up captured
by the enemy and when Daenerys and her
team offers Cersei her life in exchange
for her surrender Cersei has Musante
beheaded in front of them another cruel
show of power from a monarch who knows
how to prove a brutal point after losing
Jorah regal and miss on day in quick
succession
Daenerys might be on the brink of
succumbing to the madness that
runs in her family even though Daenerys
constantly says she wants to avoid
becoming her father the Mad King these
tragedies all point to her reaching a
breaking point before long especially as
this war continues to push her to her
limit meanwhile Cersei has long been one
of the most brutal characters on the
show and despite Tyrians pleas for
humanity and peace she's not changing
anytime soon for the moment it appears
that her ruthless streak is still
serving her well against her more nobly
intentioned enemies will her commitment
to cruelty be the difference-maker in
the coming war against Daenerys or will
it be her undoing check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about Game of Thrones are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]